you don't have to look too hard to tell
this is a portrait of Adolf Hitler it's
part of an exhibition which includes
over a hundred works of art the artists
aim is to provoke people into thinking
about the often fine line between a
dictatorship and democracy the
exhibition is raising eyebrows in
potsdam and around the world some people
believe the artwork downplays the
horrors of nazi germany the artist is
surprised this is English this is an
outrageous insinuations one picture has
been taken out of its context of
hundreds of other works but then it
becomes a headline that's what social
are and there is a suggestive question
about whether I'm for Hitler in
Parliament or against it orders in cedar
gay but Hitler on the same level as West
Germany's first post-war chancellor
konrad adenauer the conservatives want
the Hitler picture removed but there are
other opinions these only nod for wished
some suggested hanging up landscapes in
the foyer instead nobody would have said
a word about them they wouldn't have
interested anyone with no fights and the
fights are bound to continue putts Tom's
new Parliament building doesn't
officially open until next week and so
far Hitler will be at the opening party